what we have here is the new MINI
Clubman it's longer it's wider and it's
a little bit lower than before it's a
car which is aiming at the Volkswagen
Golf the MINI Clubman is like the wagon
version of the prized mini the new
generation of the Clubman offers
considerably more space than the
standard 5-door mini and so hold 27
centimeters longer and 9 centimeters
wider its individual style gives it
something of a unique appearance but it
still has that typical mini feeling as
the vehicles design chief explains
mohamad annoy MINI Clubman as CI
understanding is far so I started we
created the new MINI Clubman to be quite
distinct of course we still wanted to
create a real mini we wanted to make
sure it drives like a man and I can
guarantee that it certainly does but we
saw a great potential in setting this
car apart in terms of the look from
other minis particularly at the sides
and especially the rear the back of the
car is completely new although it's
still reminiscent of the old Clubman of
course because of the spy doors and it's
the split doors that give the Clubman
its own character guns and on character
so the new Clubman is a real mini even
if it's more maxi than ever before the
trademark protruding wheel arches and
the saucer eye headlights have been
retained along with a horizontal
structure of the lower body window light
and roof overall the Clubman appears
lower than the VW Golf which is
practically the same size well this new
MINI Clubman it's the largest mini
ever produced but it still has all the
typical mini driving traits the sporty
steering the peppy engine and as an
extra this two-piece barn door which
competitors like the golf the Audi a3
and the Mercedes a-class don't have
we're going to test the Cooper S Clubman
it has a 141 kilowatt engine and can go
from 0 to 100 km/h in just seven point
one seconds it can reach a top speed of
220 8 km/h unfortunately the whole thing
doesn't come cheap prices for the
version we tested start at 27,500 euros
on the German market and there's a long
list of additional features that are
also pricey feels like a true mini it
has all the typical traits that you
would
from a mini very direct steering a
powerful four-cylinder petrol engine and
the new 8-speed automatic gearbox the
fatso kissed and as farming says it's a
compact car extremely compact and it's
dimensions are small which is typical of
mini the front and rear overhang are
very short we've maximized the space
available in the interior while
retaining the typical mini exterior
proportions that we all love mini has
rearranged the dashboard placing the
speedometer over the steering wheel
what state are the characteristic flip
switches but the overall impression is a
little more stylish
well mini has redesigned the dashboard
there's a higher quality to the whole
car the width has increased so you get
the feeling that it's a bigger car
inside the Clubman offers 360 liters of
cargo space where the back seats folded
down that even expands to 1250 liters
the Clubman is due to go on the market
at the end of October with prices and
Germany starting at just under 24,000
euros the model will eventually be
available in three diesel and three
gasoline engine versions
you